It's whoever, not whomever.
No, it's whomever.
No, whomever is never actually right.
No, sometimes it's right.
Michael is right; it's a made-up word used to trick students.
No, actually, whomever is the formal version of the word.
Obviously, it's a real word, but I don't know when to use it correctly.
Not a native speaker.
I know what's right, but I'm not gonna say...
...because you're all jerks who didn't come see my band last night.
Do you really know which one is correct?
I don't know.
It's whom when it's the object of the sentence and who when it's the subject.
That sounds right.
Well, it sounds right but is it?
How did Ryan use it, as an object?
As an object.
Ryan used me as an object.
Is he right about that?
How did he use it again?
It was, "I wanted Michael," the subject, "to explain the computer system," the object...
Thank you.
..."to whomever," meaning us, the indirect object, which is the correct usage of the word.